à la cité des métiers à trappes on
propose chaque semaine différents
ateliers pour les demandeurs d'emploi
ici on s'occupe d'un groupe un peu
particulier les plus de 45 ans d'après
la dares 20% des 54 mille 700 chômeurs
évinois ont plus de 50 ans passé un
certain âge il devient plus difficile de
retrouver un travail
j'étais un entretien btp on m'a dit vous
n'avez pas les deux pieds dans le béton
bon ça sous-entend que vous n'êtes pas
dans le métier
et puis un jeune peut-être qu'il sera
plus disponible que vous avez vous nous
coûtera peut-être moins cher voilà c'est
tout après il faut trouver des solutions
trouver des solutions c'est ce que
propose fasse un club d'entreprises qui
luttent contre l'exclusion
gilles l'animateur propose aux
participants de faire un tri dans leurs
compétences
objectif mettre en avant celles qui
répondent aux besoins du marché et qui
les différencie des autres de parler de
façon plus plus courte de mes
compétences swissint save est utile en
effet mais bon j'ai quand même du boulot
avant d'arriver à saint pendant la
semaine de l'emploi qui démarre ce
vendredi à saint quentin en yvelines
clarisse pourra tenter de mettre en
application cette valorisation de
compétences si beaucoup de participants
ont déjà écumé des forums de l'emploi
sans succès gilles les pousse à
continuer seulement du demandeur
d'emploi c'est la pire des pires des
parcours donc je leur dis oui allez dans
tout le salon
mais ne soyez pas triste si vous n'avez
pas eu la réponse instantanément pour
ses seniors retrouver un emploi prendra
du temps mais après ensuivi un ciblage
des entreprises contactées 70% des
précédents participants ils sont arrivés